if stargate really is about return
when might it happen
this is scitrek your sci-fi tv and movie
channel
so in previous videos i've said that i
have a source
that has told me
that amazon are actually planning or
amazon have instructed mgm
to create a movie with a follow-up ten
episode series
if that is real and if it is true
can't be 100 certain until it's greenlit
we really can't be certain but if that
is true
when could we actually see stargate on
amazon which is the end of the day where
it's going to end up
captain james t kirk
of the starship enterprise
your dog tags say otherwise
they're lying
so
a movie
a sci-fi movie in particular normally
takes anything from 12 months to 18
months from when they begin filming
to when we have a theatrical release so
we have a release on stream service
basically the more special effects are
going to film the longer it takes now
that is from when filming begins
pre-production can take anything up to
six months in itself so we could be
looking at two years
but in this case i'm hoping a lot of
pre-production is actually can be done
on the quiet there's a lot of things
that can be done in the preparation for
this tea who are you taking in the cup
lord stanley's cup
hockey
remember with the ice and skating
we went to a game last year indeed
i believe the canucks of vancouver are
superior warriors
canucks eh
so lunch
so just in case you haven't seen the
other video
mgm has been bought by amazon but it is
going through the american regulators
and they're not the biggest fans of
amazon
according to my source who works for a
company close to mgm
amazon are apparently and mgm are
already quite surprised by how much
effort it is requiring an illegal battle
that seems to be brewing they thought it
would have already gone through
so that is putting another kibosh on us
seeing stargate
brad wright has talked about how this
has been in preparation for a long time
and really may have already happened but
was put on
long-term hold because of covid
covid might have been a reason why
something was put on long-term health to
begin with but let's be honest the sale
to amazon is really why this has been
put on hold and why other projects from
mgm have also been put on hold so when
might the sale of mgm actually be
finalized well some analysts are saying
that even though they still believe it
will happen but it might not happen
until the summer of 2022
if we then look at that being 18 months
until we might see a movie
we can expect to see nothing of stargate
on our screen until the christmas period
of 2023 or even early 2024.
now that i think will be a problem for
amazon
they're gonna want to announce this as
soon as possible but i believe because
stargate timekeepers the game
is coming out mid 2022. now obviously
amazon could sort of push mgm to push
that back
but i don't think they're going to want
to i think they're going to want to get
the sale of mgm through they're going to
one then want a big announcement of a
new movie a new tv series followed by
the game coming out to maximize hype
to maximize sales of the game as well
but also according to what i've been
told amazon really want to make this a
multimedia franchise with interlocking
parts a marvel style thing where the tv
shows and the movies are actually both
canon and they actually interlock with
each other they also want that with the
game
so they want the game storyline the tv
storyline and the movie storylines all
to intertwine with each other now really
to do that they need to be able to
announce this and to get the ball
rolling
from that point of the game coming out
if they can't do that
or if the gap between the game coming
out and then the movie being released is
too big then they're really going to
lose a lot of that energy the energy as
well from a lot of the online petitions
and online efforts that a lot of gators
have been putting in
they want to be able to capitalize on
that interest as well so from that point
of view i don't think we'll be too
shocked if amazon actually changed their
minds on this
and that the tv series ends up coming
first
now i don't have that it's pure
speculation on my part that's just my
opinion
excuse me
the fate of the world is hanging in the
balance and you've been sitting in your
truck finishing this i believe it was
double or nothing
okay
23 across the atomic weight of boron the
answer is 10 yes you wrote the word fat
your point
but if you think about it i don't think
amazon expected to be going through this
battle when they formulated the plan
back in may that they would have the
movie first i think they believe the
sale would go through recently quickly
it would go through the regulators
reasonably quickly and they would have
already announced now
and begun pre-production and hopefully
filming on the movie so they could get
it out within six months of the game
coming out
that hasn't happened and doesn't like
like it is going to happen
so
a more likely scenario i think and again
this is just my opinion
would be that
the sale would go through early next
year
the game would follow about three months
later
if they can announce the tv series a 10
episode short series
in that period
get a bit of the hype going and
hopefully get that on our screens by the
end of 2022 or early 2023 that would
mean only about a six-month gap between
the game and the tv series
all it would mean
is that the script for
the film maybe
would become the pilot for the tv series
that is something that has been done
before and really wouldn't be too
complicated you then create another film
if this was all successful
to me that seems like a more likely
scenario at this point i think the plan
in may
was a plan in may
these things do change they're very
fluid but i also think there's another
issue here as well and it's an issue of
image
now amazon doesn't have the greatest
image in the world and a lot of people
are very concerned about a franchise
they love going on to the amazon channel
time for me to say something profound
nothing comes to mind let's do it
they don't want to pay amazon prime or
god forbid
actually i pay my amazon prime and i pay
for mgm at the moment because i'm
watching stargate um universe so i have
to pay another five pounds a month for
the mgm channel
but that's in the uk obviously
um can you imagine if they put stargate
on the mgm channel so you have to pay
your your prime membership and then you
have to pay mgm as well
so amazon have a bit of an image problem
one of the things they could do to
improve their image is use the mgm
back catalog of products which include
stargate to create some really exciting
new projects
i believe that's why stargate is firmly
on their list as one of the projects
they want to get through as quickly as
possible
by waiting for a movie that will take at
least 18 months to produce and get onto
their screens
i'm not sure that will fit
their need to improve their image and to
basically get fans on side
because let's be honest if amazon do
this
and they produce a really good
um stargaze sci-fi series the fans are
going to watch it they're going to
get their amazon prime
um bloody subscriptions they're going to
get their mgm channel subscriptions if
they need to because they're going to be
desperate to watch this tv show this
could be a bit of a coup for amazon
but only if they can get it on their
screens quickly
so let's see what happens let's see if
the plans that are being bounded around
amazon at the moment change because i
suspect they're going to and let's
remember as well that these are still
all rumors until anything is green lit
that's all we're talking about here the
rumors
so if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit that bell
notification it really helps us out and
i'm gonna be here talking about this and
other sci-fi things
every week so leave a comment and tell
me what you think is stargate really
coming back is amazon gonna let the
sleeping giant of sci-fi return to our
screens
join us on discord there's a link in the
description where you can have a chat
with other people and
join us on facebook there's also a link
in the description you can dump all your
memes in there and have a bit of fun on
facebook and it's completely open to
anybody as long as nobody takes
advantage of it
so thanks very much thanks for watching
and i will see you next time
[Music]